YUFENG GUO: Natural language has
many challenges that are unique
and separate it from other
data types like images
and structured data.
So it requires a slightly
different approach.
Today, we'll explore
a foundational piece
of modeling natural language,
called "bag of words."
What does it mean?
And how do we use
it to process text?
Stay tuned to find out.
[THEME SONG]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to look
at how to use bag of words
to classify natural language.
Natural language is
special because it
has structure inherent in the
language while at the same time
being very free-form.
There are many ways you
can say the same thing.
And you can also say
very similar words,
and yet mean very
different things.
So in much of
machine learning, we
aim to turn our data
into matrices or tensors.
This is very natural for
images since that's already
their inherent representation.
Structured data often
meets a similar fate,
with numbers in a spreadsheet
mapping very directly to input
matrix values.
But with natural
language, we need
to somehow find a way to turn
words into numbers so we can
stick them into those matrices.
There are many ways
that we can do this.
And today, we'll focus on an
approach called "bag of words."
Let's pretend for a moment
that we're learning English
for the first time ever.
And for some reason,
the first words
we have chosen to learn
in our entire vocabulary
are these 10 shown here--
words like "dataframe" and
"graph," "plot," "color,"
and "activation."
And so we want to
be able to identify,
given some arbitrary
text, whether that topic
is about pandas,
keras, or Matplotlib.
How might we do that?
Perhaps if we looked at
a sentence, like "how
to plot dataframe
bar graph," we would
recognize just the words "plot,"
"dataframe," and "graph."
The rest of the sentence would
look like a foreign language,
just gibberish.
Knowing only those three
words in this sentence,
though, we might
still be able to get
some sense of what it's about.
And the way you might capture
this information in an array
or matrix would be to first
make an array that represents
your entire vocabulary.
So in this case, we have
an array of just length 10.
We'd set all those
values to 0 and turn
on the array indices
that correspond
to the words in the sentence
by setting them to 1.
Notice that this has
nothing to do with the order
the words appear in
the input sentence,
but everything to do with
the order of the words
in our vocabulary list.
So now we've encoded or
translated the English sentence
into an array of numbers
based on our somewhat limited
understanding of English.
The words we don't
recognize, we'll just ignore.
Notice that this has the
effect of scrambling up
the order of the words,
like, say, a bag of words.
Of course, we should do
the same for our labels.
This is much simpler, since
there are only three of them.
In our case, we
have some sentences
that have more than
one label attached
to them at the
same time, however,
since a sentence can talk
about multiple topics at once.
In that case, we want to set
all the relevant indices to 1,
leaving the rest as 0, just
like we did for the words
from our training data.
Now we've turned the
inputs as well as
the outputs, which
both used to be words,
into arrays of numbers.
And we can let machine
learning do what it does best--
map one set of numbers to
another set of numbers.
All the heavy lifting is
done in the preprocessing
as we transformed
or encoded that text
into numerical representations.
Bag of words is a pretty simple
approach for doing this task,
though it's worth pointing
out that it might surprise you
how well it works
in some situations.
How might we build a bag
of words modeled with code?
Keras has a convenient
preprocessing library
that we can use to handle
much of this for us.
Using the Tokenizer
class, we can
select the size
of the vocabulary
we'd like to utilize.
In our example, we just had 10
words, which is quite small,
but in our code, let's choose
something bigger, like 400.
This will then be fit on
the entire body of the text
from your training
data, selecting out
the most common 400 words.
With the tokenization process
complete, building the model
becomes quite
straightforward and similar
to working with other
structured data.
Since each row is now just
an input of 1s and 0s,
using something as simple as
a standard, fully connected,
deep neural network
can be quite effective.
If you're planning on having
multiple label classification,
where more than one label might
be true for a single input,
as we do here, be sure that
we choose a sigmoid activation
instead of the more common
Softmax activation function,
and pair it with binary
cross-entropy loss.
So there you have it--
the bag of words
model in a nutshell.
Understanding how
bag of words works
and its advantages
and drawbacks can
help you build your foundation
in natural language processing
as you move on to more advanced
approaches to encoding text.
For more details
and examples, be
sure to check out the expanded
blog post I have linked below
in the description.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, get started on your
natural language processing
journey by checking
out the tensor flow
word embedding tutorial
I've linked below
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]